if we are counting down to music's
biggest night on Sunday and all week
we're traveling down the road to the
Grammys
[Music]
you know she's feeling today it's her
birthday happy birthday to you Alicia
Keys 37 years old and still looking on
fire she is sold more than 30 million
albums worldwide and one Grammy for
songs like no one that you're hearing
they're fallen and Empire State of Mind
her husband Grammy award-winning
producer is Swiss bees Swizz Beatz
rather he's the man behind songs like
Kanye West ultralight beam Jay Z's on to
the next one on to the next one and
Beyonce's ring the alarm tonight
Recording Academy will honor the couple
with the producers and engineers wing
Awards we sat down with them ahead of
their big night for their first
interview together the two of you
together are receiving the producer and
engineer wing award from the Recording
Academy this is what they said about why
you're getting it by the way Swizz Beatz
and Alicia Keys set new precedents for
excellence their contributions are
paramount that you too are an undeniable
force in the industry mmm I like the
sound of that
mmm like that too we are
[Music]
Alicia started playing piano at seven we
know that you started DJing in high
school
[Music]
so music has been a big part of your
lives for a very long time so what does
it mean to you both as we sit here
getting ready to celebrate Grammy
weekend well for me is music is the
instrument of life I agree I feel like
music is the it's the answer it's the
reason it's so powerful that's why we
all love it and that's why we can't live
without it it's like Quincy Jones said
there's two things you can't live
without water and music yeah and I was
like yes music is just one of the things
that bond power couple Alicia Keys and
Swizz Beatz
he's one of hip-hop's most critically
acclaimed Grammy winning producers she's
released six studio albums and even
after 15 Grammy wins she's focused on
what's ahead the best things that I've
ever done is coming Kanye West said you
are the best rap producer in the
business he said you work with with with
Beyonce and Jay and Metallica and Gwen
Stefani and Donna I mean so what do
people get when they gets whispies as
their producer they get super honesty a
lot of challenges a good time you're
gonna get positive energy when you when
you in the studio with me know Alicia
said you know he can work with anybody
and he makes everything all right he
knows how to make you feel comfortable
what happens when you're working on
music and he does something that you
don't think is great or she does
something that you don't think it's
great it's easy this is very hard for me
to find something that she can't do
great great great swears that's great
quickly monitor your taser he's brutally
honest I'm like you better could you
like be a little sweeter with the way
you but this is a thing that I like
about the two of you together because it
does feel that you are each other's
cheerleaders but is there ever healthy
competition between the two of you you
know I would say no because I feel that
one of the things that really works
as we're very different even a style of
music is different from my style music
we complement each other as opposed to
kind of ever in each other's way or
should there before thinking about she
did that not to do this
we don't rather like that healthy vibe
for any couple you know a lot of men are
scared of powerful women right and so
mmm I know she's powerful her power
doesn't scare you no that's cool Swizz
recently moved beyond the studio last
fall he earned a degree from Harvard
University's owner president management
program it's an accomplishment that
inspired him to create the motto from
the Bronx to Harvard and number one
thing that people want to talk to me
about now when I walk around this
Harvard a lot of people said man we
graduated you know it's not like a meat
thing it's a wee thing what did you
think when he said this was what he
wanted to do I was so excited and I've
been so invested in this journey with
him but the first time I'll never forget
we were literally in this room when he
got the letter of acceptance and it was
like such a moment because it was so
powerful like this dream that he had to
do this by the way it's in order to do
that there's a lot that's requires even
be accepted yeah you can't just be like
hey yeah I'm coming in yeah like you
can't be I'm Swizz Beatz maker producer
yeah except you got turned down three
times the last time I was like you know
what I've tried you know three times
maybe this is not for me bang and that's
why you really can't ever give up
ambition sure runs in the family
Alicia is stepmom to prince kassim and
Nicole together the two have three year
old Genesis and seven year old Egypt
[Music]
he made headlines at five years old when
he created an original Beach yeah yeah
or Kendrick Lamar Young Jeezy they
didn't know Kendrick was he just seen
him and was attracted to his like yeah
[Music]
he's telling ya tell me Kendrick about
music that's electric hear that
that's a piano I played piano he's just
like finding his way with Kendrick and
epic and then he comes up with a beef
for him and Kendrick ends up using it
yeah thanks I don't even have a
chuckling Kendrick that was before you
came we were talking about kids and I
said don't we want a baby Alicia and he
said yes so what does mommy Alicia say
that would make me so talk to the
universe universe but I'm not ready
right now universe hear me loud and
clear same here no we're not ready but
you are opens to a baby Alicia it would
just think about that universe alright
universe alright they've been together
eight years they said in that time
they've never had a serious argument
that they've never raised their voice
that when they have conflict they sit
down they Oh everybody says
communication but these two really do
communicate so I'd like to talk to you
about something I thought that was
interesting and the Harvard Business
School now wants to do a case study on
the two of them together oh I like to I
think is very very very cool student to
case study yeah the Bronston case
exactly what happened so congratulations
it is her birthday today she turns 37
great interview Cal I really like them
both so much so Congrats Congrats